Ama
bir gün otobüs durağının okula doğru
yürürken
insanın gözleri inceledim insanın
gözlerinin içinde bir yalnızlık bir öfke
bir nefes yazıyordum Aslında bu varken
otobüse bindim
Otobüsün içinde duymak istemediğim
şeyler döndüm içindeki birkaç Grup insan
Multijet nasıl öldürmek istediği
hakkında nasıl hepsini kötü insanlar
olduğu hakkında konuşuyordu
bunu duyduktan sonra şunu düşündüm biz
bu insanlar olarak nasıl bir grup
İnsanın bu kadar nefret duyabiliyorsunuz
onları tanımıyoruz bile hepsiyle konuşma
ihtimaliniz ile yok ama sadece
doğdukları coğrafya yüzünden onlara
karşı bir nefret besliyorsunuz Bunun
nedeni düşündüm de bunun asıl nedeni
korkunun öfke ve sonra nefrete dönüşmesi
bu insanlardaki en büyük korku
bilinmeyen korkutur
çocukken Karanlıktan korkuyorum
Herkesin herkesin olduğu gibi karakter
kokan var mıdır çocuk yani
mi Evet gördüğünüz gibi Çünkü Karanlık
korkusu en Temel İçgüdü denizden biridir
bir insan bilmediği şeyden acayip korkar
kanun siyahından korkuyorduk kalın
içinde ne olabileceğinden korkuyorduk bu
korku insanları anlamaktan da oluşabilir
çocuktan git Yabancılarla konuşmama
denir ya da yabancı burada konuşmayı
nedir bunun nedeni yabancıları
tanımıyoruz yabancıların beni nasıl
çalıştığını bilmiyoruz anlamıyorsun
Aklından ne geçiyor ne geçiyor
düşüncelerini duygularını herhangi bir
fikrimiz yok
Bundan dolayı onları bilmiyoruz bunu bir
grup insan var taşıdığımızda da örnek
veriyorum bir kabile olduğumuzu şu mu
Çünkü antik çağdan beri var bir kabul
olduğu şu farklı bir kabile
karşılaşacağız kültürlerini
bilmiyorsunuz neler yediğini
bilmiyorsunuz ve bunları bilmediğimiz
için Onlara karşı bir korku duruyorsunuz
sonra bu korku öfkeye sonra nefrete
dönüşüyor Çünkü korktu Sen neden nefret
ederiz bildiğiniz gibi çok homofobi gibi
olsun terimlerde Sobi korkudan gelir ama
homofobik dediğimizi nefretten
bahsediyorsun bunun dedim korkunuz soran
nefrete dönüşmesidir bir şimdi karşınıza
bir tane şifre etkilemedi var bunun
adımlarını anlatacağım size açıklamalar
vereceğim
doğduğumuzdan beri küçüklükten beri bize
Bazı Düşünceler aktarılıyor cinsellikle
alakalı olsun yabancılar kötü ile
alakalı olsun Yabancılarla kötüdür
onlarla konuşmayın ya da sakın ercikti
birey olma gibi cümleler duyabiliriz
yani cinsiyetçi söylemler koyabiliriz
bunlara aklımıza yerleşiyor bunu
farkında olmasak bile şu an hepimiz de
mutlaka bir daha bilinçaltımızı
homofobik cinsiyetçi ayracı ya da bir
grup insanın aciz eden düşünce var bir
fark etmek nasıl düşen gelir sonra bu
düşünceler bu video arkası dediğimiz
farklı şeyler neden oluyor Örneğin
migrasyon ol bu
suyu olmana rağmen çok iyi bir insansın
bu cümlemde şu düşünebilirsiniz Aslı
nefret söylemi gerçekleştiriyorum bu
cümle dediğim şey karşı Ömer'e rağmen
aslında bir inçlik dağıtımda
şöyle bir düşünce yazıyor Suriyeliler
kötü insan onlardır O yüzden iyi olması
istislah Bundan dolayı Bunların agresyon
böyle nefret söylemi değil Bunu
bilinçaltında kötü düşünceli olan
insanlarda izleyebiliriz inceleyebiliriz
bu cümle kırmak ilk başı hata gibi ama
doğal bir şekilde Eğer düşüncenin
sorgulamaz sanız böyle olur burs Sonra
nefes söylemek alıyoruz Şimdi neden bu
kadar tehlikeli
bunu açıklamak için bilgi biraz
bahsetmek istiyorum artık Kimimiz
kalmıyor anlamsızlaşıyor Uz şu an
gençlerimiz düşünelim ne kadar dine
karşı inancını azaldığını ne kadar
milliyetçilik duygusundan bu ülkeye ait
olmadığını hissettiniz düşün Eskiden
dinin de bir kimlik bulurdun Eskiler
ülkene milletine bir kimlik vurdum artık
ya bunlar internet olsun ya da gençlerin
bu modern dünyadaki adı anlamsızlık
olsun bunun yüzünden yok olmaya
başlıyorsun iyi istek bir nesil
yetişiyor ve bu nesil Kimliksiz
olduğundan bağlantılı olmadığını
herhangi bir yere bir anlam arayışı
içerisinde sürekli bu anlamıyor Bazen
yaşam sizleri doldurabilir bu siyasete
dönecek siyasi anlamışım düşün bir
anlamı yok geçtiniz ve karşılıklı
korkunuz var sosyal bir platform bunu
kullanıyor şimdi sosyal medya platformu
nasıl maçı ilgili toplamak ilgili
topladık çok daha çok onu Platformu
tutmak bunu en çok sadece duygular korku
korktuğum da Takip edersin ne olacak
acaba öfke öfke olduğunda tepki verirsin
yorum yazarsın bunları kullanarak bizi
kullanıyorlar ilk başta hafif korkusu
olan büyücüler al bu olay yüzünden çok
sağ kayabilir örnek veriyorum ben de bu
durumu yaşadım ben de hafif güce karşı
korku vardı YouTube'da bunu ile
bilgilendirici video izledim düzenli
video altına baktığımda direkt nefes
Onun için aşağıda görebilirsiniz nasıl
suyu önünden bunları izledim ve hafif
hafif şöyle birşey gerçekleşiyor abi
bunları o kadar duydukça ve karşı gruba
konuşamadım daha atmam normalleşiyor
Evet böyle düşünmek normal Evet bunu
herhangi bir hata yok herkes tarafından
açalım mı bu
Çok teşekkürler en çok kullanılan sosyal
medya sonu açın
Çok teşekkür ederim birkaç kaydını ne
zaman siyasi provoke edecek bir şey
diyeceksin her bir siyasi içerik
olabilir bir tane başı söyle tekrar
alabilir miyim
[Müzik]
bu
Duydunuz mu bunun gibi başka söyle
görüyorsunuz sadece biberi minik bir
olay artık karşınıza çıkmaya başlıyor
çünkü benzeri çektiğinizde onu içeride
posta şunu diyor Suriyelileri tehdit
etti ve benzeri bir cümle kuruyor burada
görüyorsunuz ki bu artık süre karşınıza
çıkıyor Şu an açıldı kaçta çıkmasa bile
mutlaka görüyorsunuz size Bunun
farkındasınız bu insanları
kutuplaştırıyor bu insanlar Fatih öne
geçiyor Eskiden aldığımız bilgi aynı
yerden dedi belirli coğrafyada alıyorduk
o köyde yaşadığında o köydeki bilgi
anladık Ama artık internet şöyle ucundan
şu an sağınıza yada solunuza oturan bir
diğer size tamamen farklı çocuğa sahip
olabilir sıramızı gibi bir şeyler
hissediyor sonundaki bile anarşiye
polisim isteyebilir bunun mümkün yapan
şey sosyal medyanın şu an bu hale
gelmesi bunu dedikten sonra ben değil
Hikayem devam edin oy nefes sonra atmam
aşmaya başladım ben de sormaya başladım
Nasıl sevdiğini BBP başladım olarak
düşünüyordum Ondan sonra İnternet
stokastik biraz bahsetmek istiyorum
çünkü acil nefes oynamaya başladı
Piramit'teki sukasi terörizm şu durmama
klasik terörizmde bilgiler vardır
takipçi edinir ve bu takip ederek var
emir verir ama model çağımızdaki çoğu
telefonu O yüzden değildir Amerika'da
olan silahı ateşler bakın ya da 2017'de
gece kulübü zeka saldırı bakın Oradaki
adam Herhangi bir şeyde bir lider
tarafından çekilmedi internet içerikleri
tükettiği için o saldırıyı
gerçekleştirdi ve bu saldırı
gerçekleşirse ve internet onlarda Kilis
etti bu gibi olayı artık Günümüzde çok
beğeniyor Çünkü biz gençler olarak
anlamsız ve hissetmesi olduğu için
hedefliyoruz ve bu siyasi
organizasyonlar ne sosyal medyanın
yardımıyla Biz yavaşça sağa doğru çekip
sağa doğru çekip sağa doğru çekiyor sol
çekiyorsa oldu çıkıyorsa olduğunu
çekiyor o Çünkü
sosyal medya Bunu istiyor ilginizi
istiyor ve artık bu insanlar kendi
toplulukları oluştura biliyorlar neden
sosyal medyada sayfalar var aynı
insanlarla konuşuyorsun takip ediyor
Herkes birbirini Bunun nedeni bu şunu
oluşuyor bir ekosistem oluşuyor artık
kendi şu yazan başka bir şey
görmüyorsunuz karşı düşünce zaten
göreceksiniz Çünkü sosyal medya
platformu alıyor ki bunu ona gösterirsem
tekrar azaltıyor çünkü onun senin
karşılamıyor bu sene çıkamıyoruz yakın
bir zamandı ve Artık bunlar köpek
ısırdığında bir şey dönüşüyor bazı
cümleler var bazı kelimeler vardır
aklında bir şey getirmez örnek veriyorum
ailemize saldırıyorlar Bu da ne
alıyorsunuz Ayrıca saldırı şu demek
aklımda sadece bir saldırı gelir ama
bazı topluluklarda bazı örgütler de bu
elegent için kol söz ve ve siyasi
figürler en İzbe diyor Aklımda
bahsederken Çünkü
antikatör nefes diyecekler Neden böyle
bir şey diyorsun çok karşı çok maçınız
edeceği Ama artık kendi şifre diyorsun
bu şifre sosyal
edilebiliyor aralarında şakalar oluyor
bu sayfaya girdiğinizde ya da herhangi
bir şaka sayfasına gittiğinizde
Oradaki bir olarak adlandırmak çok fazla
karşılaşacaksınız ve Artık bunlar şifre
leşiyor bu şifre makale saldır gibi
kelimeler oluşuyor örnek veriyorum
tepede diye bir tane çizgi film
karakteri vardı Çok basit herhangi bir
şekilde kullanılmıyordu küçük çizgi
romanda vardı ama artık günümüzde
internetteki siyasi figürler onlara
nefes söyleme okuldan başladı Naziler
olsun savcılar olsun bu insanlar onu
kullanmaya başladı ikişer Devleti artık
günümüzde çoğu mobilizasyon nefes
alınarak algılıyor bu şunu internetteki
kullanılan Şifa gerçekten gel Ya sen
burada başka mobilizasyon nefes söyleme
alakalı bazı örnekler vereyim Sivas
tıkla artık o derece ulaşılabiliyor bazı
sembolleri internet
bu yüzden şiddet şiddet teyze şu an
nefes ve onun şiddeti var kişiye ulaşma
tehlikesi asıl bizi korkutmak olan şey
olmalı Çünkü bazı olaylar oluyor örnek
veriyorum evden gördüğünüz Uçuşun
oğlumuz olabilir siz olabilirsiniz
kardeşimiz olabilir biri olunuz ve
sonrası adam duruyor zor odasını
çekiyorsun duruyor ve Instagram
paylaşıyor Bu olay yakın zamanda oldu
ki bu adam rastgele erce bir birey
yürürken evde evine doğru gidiyordu onun
çekti ve dövme internette paylaştı bunun
gibi olayların olması bile bunun kanadı
Çünkü bu adam internete paylaşa sebebini
düşün artık nefret söyleminde olan
insanı bu noktada ileriye bakacaklar
Çünkü ileri ideoloji ederler bunu
gördükçe daha çok şiddetli mi yapmaya
devam edecekler bu Amerika'da
görebiliriz silahla ateş memelerde
insanlar örnek alıyor ben de yapabilirim
diyor yakın zamanda bir tane Kilisesi
yani ödemek için bir bastı ve bunların
hepsini manifestosunu okuduğumuzda
internetteki YouTube'da örnek veriyorlar
salgın fakat olsun Ben şifre bir
YouTube'da örnek veriyorlar Bunun nedeni
bu insanlar da o dilini iniyor YouTube
olsun Onlar da anlamsız bilmesin Biz
gençler dini sembollerimiz ülkemiz ve
bunun gibi balığımızı kıldığını
kıldığında ve ayrıldığında bir boşluk
yaşadık var ya boşu yaşadığınızda bu
anlamsızlığı için Düştüğümüzde bu siyasi
örgütler bizi alıyor diyor ki sana
Allah'ım benim sana bir yuuyo vereyim
sana bir topluluk vereyim ben de bu
noktadayım Ben de onu arıyordum ve
siyasi düşünce abi buluyordum nefes
söyleme olsun Bunun gibi şeyler de
buluyordum ne zaman fark ettim hatamı
işler karşıdan bir de konusunda cidden
bir süre ile konuştuğumda Bu insanlarla
konuştuğumuzda Bu bariyerleri
yıkadığımızda bir ön yargınız varsa
bunları sorgulamakta ben neler
düşünüyorum aklından neler geçiyor
bunlar cidden sorguladığınız da
anlıyorum ben süreye konuştuğumda fark
ettim ki hepsi böyle değil bu nereden
geliyor sonra daha çok içeri sorgulamaya
başladım sorguladığımda fark ettim
Bunların hepsi yanlış bulanıyorsa abartı
bunları çok Propaganda benim etmek için
değişik istiyorsan Şu an burada bulunan
herkesin şunu yapmasını istiyorum siyasi
Fikri karşı olan bir insanla konuşun
sadece Satılmış solcuyla konuşuruz
olduysanız bir sadece konuş sen bu
saatte artık onlar karşı beslediğiniz
nefret anlayamadığımız içinden geldin
nefretini yok ediniz herhangi bir grup
bir veya öneriniz varsa onlarla konuşun
Ancak bu şekilde ilerleyebiliriz
Çünkü şiddet Remzi sonuna bakın
bu soykırım taşıdılar